there's something
you really cannot lie
[Music]
your real name is Harry Harry James
barber Bam's you changed your name
because why the FBI is looking for me to
wrap the bank in California the biggest
bank heist in US history look it up I'm
gonna rip off the President of the
United States it doesn't get any bigger
or better than that seemed like a good
idea at a time how much we talking about
as much as 30 million I'm in yeah you're
in get out you check this out you see
that buddy
that's the bank what they're there for
we're gonna crush some grapes it's a hot
tub what's the hot tub sorry i shanked
my drive I'll shake you you sherbert
colored ass everybody does the job we
should be looking at Nixon's money
within an hour are you gonna shut off
the alarm I'm working on it
I know how you can do it firing a hole
away
[Music]
it remains that's when it all started to
fell sideways water 56 boxes we're
always looking for something specific
he's a crook and crooks don't know how
to stop when they're ahead you never
told me your dad was too Sheriff why
this buddy why these safe deposit boxes
the last time the bureau assigned a
hundred agents to enjoin of killing his
assassin John
Harry Steve McQueen I don't know what to
call you anymore finally Steve McClean
what's your name again Steve McQueen
you